yes afternoon everybody this is the uh
special committee on
commissions on uh the day before
Halloween October
30th
2023 and I imagine uh today uh looking
towards uh what needs to get done that
today is going to be pretty much a
working session because we have today is
is a deadline for us to get our inputs
into
OS via we're going to be going via uh
legi admin committee we're going to put
make sure we put together an amendment
that captures what we want to do through
that committee and it's going to be uh
was it
84 s sp84 s sp84 is is is going to be
the the vehicle for this first wave of
uh
uh reducing committees and
commissions uh and uh we're honored to
have uh former speaker shirtliff with us
because I know he has an opinion he
wants to express to us on one of the
potential uh actions and we do have a
quorum so why don't we get started uh
what I'd like to do is go go through
each go down the list um and
um speaker short lift do you you have a
a place you want to you need to be right
away I can put you at the top of
it wow wow it is getting thick so all
right so we'll just go let's just go
down the list and ask the vice Cher to
take us take us through these one at a
time we have uh potential of 10 I
believe and yes we do and I would like
to get at least uh eight or nine of the
10 into the uh into legi admin for for
Action so John okay thank you Mr
chairman uh there our first uh item on
the list uh is HB
258 uh chapter 20 2711 loss of
2001 and representative Wilhelm uh was
going to take care of
this Matt you want to speak to it yeah I
will I
so I had volunteered a little tongue and
cheek because it seemed like this was
the the no-brainer one that uh needed to
be put on the list
um and so I need to go back let let me
find my notes but I spoke with Deborah
about it and she said this is absolutely
one that should be on the list there are
no appointees right now okay good so
okay excellent so that takes number one
right off right off the list
excellent so what's going to happen is
uh our representative from legi admin
are going to take our output from this
meeting uh down to L
uh uh right as as before the meeting
gets too long here and uh make sure it
gets inputed so that when they they have
their committee meeting coming up that
this will be hopefully it'll be a a
group a group of of uh on the list
hopefully it'll make make it depending
on the on the committee because it is a
non gerain Amendment it'll be on consent
I would I would hope we'll see because
it's a non- gerine Amendment we are
going to have a public hearing before we
execute yeah
perfect number number two four 271 sorry
just trying to confirm that quietly uh
that's
28 chapter
27 27 sorry two chapter
271k okay next on our list is 4 colon
9-1 commission to oversee the John G wet
Memorial and I have it on my list that
we are going to discuss this and
representative shli is here to discuss
it with us
floor is yours Sir Mr
Speaker got that
title thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Steve schleff and I represent M ma
district 15 W want to conquer the
village of Penacook and I would um I
really don't have anything planned to to
speak about just to say I hope the
committee does not um abolish this
commission um
as you probably know the whet commiss
statue Memorial was dedicated in 19 U
let me think
2017 and it's to our late Governor the
ambassador to England dur World War II
and
um the committee
private funding our committee raised
over $300,000 for the wet Memorial and
in a way I look at the memorial of
course primarily being to honor Governor
wet for his service to our state and to
our country he was also the first
director of the Social
Security um Administration that's why
our social security numbers are
003 in fact Governor W was supposed to
get
00101001 as the chair of that commission
and being a humble man he said no I'll
just take whatever randomly and that
went to a woman here in caret so that's
my trivia for the day but
um the memorial is dedicated to Governor
wet but in my heart it's also dedicated
to a good friend of many of us um the
fmer commissioner uh van McLoud from the
cultural Affairs I chaired the wiet
committee that you with a lot of help
from a lot of people we raised the money
and but if anybody was the chair a vice
chair it was vanan and he died when we
had about 90% of the work
done and uh so if you look at the
memorial and look to the left there's a
small plaque there uh dedicated to Van
where it's his words after every wi and
upward and um and those were engraved
next to the memorial as our way of
thanking van for everything he did uh
individually and as a commissioner of
cultural
resources the commission is made up of
three people
myself uh Paul Smith the uh Clerk and
Terry Johnson from the New Hampshire
Department of historical
resources and we have not met and I
think in some ways this committee may
look at that as being a negative or you
haven't done anything uh since the
dedication because nothing has needed to
be done um I myself look at the Statue
and it's being maintained it's in good
shape the purpose for having this in
part in the
legislation is that and I wrote this to
my friend I think it's in your records
now the email I sent to my friend from
Deary I have seen over the years a
number of times when the department of
AD Administration has not received
funding they probably should have gotten
but didn't and we've seen a lot of our
cultural and historic properties degrade
over the years um such as the um Robert
Frost Farm in
Terry uh the um Wentworth uh cool
mansion in the Sea Coast and the Janu
Webster farm and now in Salsbury
originally in web in Franklin and those
who have heard I wanted to make sure at
least during my lifetime that if
anything happened to this statue or or
the Shrubbery or anything that the state
for some reason could not take care of
that this group would raise the money we
already have about 5,000 on hand but
raise any additional funds to make sure
that that was maintained uh I'm so proud
of the number of out of state people
that we have coming to our state house
to visit and many of them include the
statue of uh John wet and especially
those coming from England where he
served
so closely with the British people
refusing to leave London during the
blitz it would actually go out and help
the fire brigades go to the rubble
looking for the injured and the deceased
um in some respects John wiet is more
known and even probably better loved in
England than he is here and I've been
out there times when English visitors
have been and to oh God bless John wet
um so anyway that concludes all I had to
say to this group but I do hope you will
vote against it if it's a question of
taking it away and not to take it away
from this commission but I know it does
say the member of a house uh needs to be
on this group and if that is something
um that I could put a bill in to change
I'd be more than glad to and let me just
close by giving you my suggestion I know
that you're dealing with the effect of
all these bills and I know you're trying
to deal with the cause and I think part
of the problem we have in the
legislature is no matter if a person
whatever they put in for a bill it's
going to get filed some could file a
bill saying make the TIY fly the state
insect of New Hampshire I need a
commission to look at this and in
instead of telling him that we don't
have TI flies in New Hampshire or
representative sure filed that four
years ago and it didn't
pass I would like to see a Sixers
commission a committee in the speakers
office like the speaker's Advisory Group
three Democrats three Republicans and if
anybody puts in a bill to form a
commission it would go before this six
person group first and in order to get a
bill to go to OS after that you need a
60% a 60% vote of the six people so four
out of six if it fails then like going
to uh toile a laate pill go to the floor
of the house and ask permission there I
think we have a lot of our new people
that think I would have put a bill in
for a commissioner on this and that not
realizing that one may have been done
just a couple sessions ago but I'd like
to see that check in Balance so that we
don't get so many of these bills coming
in and somehow and some of them I'm
surprised how they actually came into
law and and now you're suffering the
consequences of it that's all I've got
Mr chairman any questions I'd be glad to
answer them any any questions from the
committee
comments
yes thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you for coming in representative
shff uh thank you for giving us your
point of view as well well as the
history of what's going on yeah in um
2012 and 2013 we had legislation to uh
have this statute constructed then in um
2015 we had a bill come before us
establishing the commission so it's what
eight years ago um and you say the
commission has met since then and you've
raised money since then and I noticed in
looking at the original bills that
passed if you uh in the um it says this
bill establishes a committee to study
the construction of a permanent Memorial
to Governor John Gilbert winant on State
Property other than the State House
grounds and wouldn't you know it's just
across the street at the library and uh
in a very prominent position um I'm
wondering I also have the legislation
that established the joint legislative
historic committee and the
responsibilities of the historic
committee and it wasn't too many years
ago when we had all of the statues
around the state house inspected we had
to do a repair to the large one behind
the state house water was coming out of
the foot so had to do some repairs and
then the term that was used was this um
company from Massachusetts waxed the
statues I think it's just a rubbing on
of a compound it's not necessarily wax
because that didn't make sense um with
the governor wian statue just across the
street I'm wondering if it might make
sense to include it in responsibilities
of the joint historic committee so that
when these statues get inspected and
taken care of that on will too just just
wondering what do you think I thank my
friend my friend from uh uh seast to who
to ask me that
um I'd like to see it stay in the W
commission hands because these the
people that have real vested interests
in the Statue um I suppose to put it
under the historic commission would be
fine I'd have no objection I just want
oversight um you know I remember I think
it was 10 years ago there was a
beautiful Victorian Cottage on the
grounds of the New Hampshire
hospital now the John wi yeah John
Gallen um office complex it was not
being used by the state so it was left
to abandon for in for six months the
water the pipes
froze and by the time they found it six
months later there black mole they had
te that beautiful old Cottage down I
just don't want to see things like the
Shrubbery should die and the state say
well we got to put our resources where
we get the mo we'll let it go you know
the sharberry represents sharberry that
grows in New Hampshire as well as in
England as part of the silent tribute to
the governor um those are the things I
want to make somebody should hit the
lamp for some reason and that breaks
that that would be taken care of and not
put off for another time but if the you
know I've got a lot of respect for the
historic uh joint historic committee and
uh that would be fine I'd have no
problem with that either
yes go ahead I just want to say thank
you very much and thanks for
understanding we'll do the best we can
and you know we will and um I know this
is near and dear to your heart so thank
you thank you any other com
yes thank which way does it go okay
thank you for uh coming uh
representative shirtliff my recollection
is that when we were working on this in
the previous committee on committees we
had um we had a a memorial like this I
think it was to the police or it was to
safety or something and that was a
similar situation where when the bill
was originally passed it had to do with
the commission being pulled together to
construct something and it was easy
enough I mean I think we included in our
bill language that basically showed the
evolution of the situation got rid of
the language that talked about the
construction of the item what I'm sorry
I'm forgetting what Memorial was and it
simply said that the commission would um
continue and its responsibility would be
for the maintenance and continued
support of the memorial so it reflected
the rea the um reality of the situation
and it basically was just updating the
statute so I don't have the language in
front of me but it might be easy and
enough to just include something like
that in our bill our Amendment because
speaking for myself at this point I
would see I I would respect the request
of Representative or speaker shirtliff
and not repeal this commission but we
could do a simple update of the
language any other I think that was the
law enforcement memorial out in front of
the Lop that you're referring to we did
form an early committee uh uh a study to
look at this idea of farming a memorial
and we did our report at the end saying
that we concluded that a memorial should
be done to honor Ambassador wet and um
and out of that a private uh group came
together because it was all private
fundraising for it uh there was no State
expense as far as the upkeep maintenance
having we talked to our uh Chief of
Staff uh you know talking to Terry it's
SP the understand that the state you
know maintains it like everything else
but this is part of the original bill
this uh oversight commission and again
it's just a fail safe um in the event
that for some reason the state can't do
what may need to be done um like I said
uh you know that really means a lot to
me that to a lot of people for so many
reasons you know for the governor
struggle with mental health problems uh
his Service uh um you know like his say
his late son Rivington wet once said to
uh Bill Gardner the farmer Secretary of
State he said my father will never
receive the honors and recognition he
deserves because of the way he died and
he took his own life in November of
1947 and um and the dedication that made
me feel so good he had since passed on
Rivington to know he's looking down and
saying yeah your father has been on it
and uh and what he suffered with his own
mental health problems is one of wasn't
a detriment it was one of the things
that he uh he should be out of his
father for in the way he handled things
so that was a long long answer to a
short question I apologize yes
ma'am thank you and thank you for coming
and for sharing all of that I um I just
want to say what my thinking is as we go
through all of these committees and
commissions is that we don't want to
just get rid of them just to get rid of
them or just to say here's another one
we can cut you know we really want to
look at how um we've looked at how time
and resource intensive a commission or
committee is for staff you know that's
kind of one of the things we've been
thinking about and and uh just trying to
remember that some of these committees
and commissions um it's really good and
fine if they don't have work to do at a
certain period but that doesn't mean
they don't have other work to do in the
future and we shouldn't drop that off
and and leave it um and so I feel
like those two things that have been in
my mind um really apply in this
situation you know it's not a time and
resource intensive committee or
commission that the staff F would find
burdensome you know and it's not um so
huge that you can never get people
together you know and it's uh only six
years old so it's just not going to have
a ton of Maintenance at this point to be
frank um so it really is a future
oriented commission um so I just wanted
to let the um let folks know what I'm
kind of thinking of when I look at this
commission and the um work that it uh
does thank you
yeah okay
um assuming that's our final comment on
on this
particular item let let me say that
um my recommendation is out also out of
deference to uh former
speaker I think that what I want to
recommend to the committee is that we
look at
maybe moving this under the oaces or the
control of the historic uh
committee however not now yeah let's
let uh former speaker shirle think about
that and maybe communicate that thought
with the uh the folks that have been
working on with you on this and that if
we could bring it we could take it off
our list now and put a uh a bookmark on
this maybe a future action maybe we
bring it up through the rules committee
that we added as a a special legislation
if it if it's appropriate to do it that
way uh and and not included on this list
of 10 or so and uh let's Let It rest and
we'll think about it how does that thank
you Mr chairman for your kind words and
and your thoughts and it's greatly
appreciated by me without been speaking
to the other two members I think to move
it to the historical commission The
Joint historical commission would be
fine with them as well as it is with me
just that the fact that somebody else is
looking over the statue and it's uh and
people especially connected with the
legislature you know here I go again
John winer's first uh position was
member of the New Hampshire house for W7
in conet and long as there's more eyes
on it that that would be fine and and
you have your finger in the rules
committee right I know some people on
there yes so they get a brilliant Vice
chair perhaps you could if this strategy
uh is supported by this committee
perhaps you could car it would be
supported by the Vice chair as well
representative uh you had some comments
as well yeah so I just want to make sure
it's clear you're okay with us repealing
it and giving it to the historical today
representative yeah
okay yes John representative thank you
the reason I brought that up about this
store committee is that's in law and
we're not going to get rid of it no and
we you know all of us are going to be
gone at some point what one way or
another one way or another and um either
out of here or gone one way or the other
and so I was thinking Perpetual care
yeah that that'd be perfect that make me
sleep even better at
night we're going to put put a statue up
to representative wall making that
comment
yes sir uh Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion I move that uh we remove four
call 9-1 from the removal
list okay is there a second for
that
yes second it get we get
that all in favor say I I I
oppos unanimous so are you still Jan it
was hard for me not to Second my friend
from Deary's a
motion but I want to thank all of you m
you Mr chairman and the vice chair and
the members of uh this committee I
know God bless you you're doing God's
work on this committee I know it's not
easy and I thank you you're welcome to
stay for the remainder of the meeting or
if you want I'm gonna quit while I'm
ahead I think Matt had a question for
you well I guess I'm just I'm curious
how we want to move forward with this it
sound it sounded like there was some
interest in uh moving it to the to
oversight of the memorial to the Joint
historic commission yeah I I what my my
recommendation before we took the vote
was that we look at doing that but not
right now that that we do that in after
we get all this other stuff put away
right that we do that with another
vehicle maybe through the rules
committee that because we're we're out
of time in terms of ol get this
so uh maybe you know maybe after the
first of the year we can look at it with
the with the embracement of the rules
committee we could put put it on a
special legislation that uh Mr chairman
yes I was under the understanding that
he said he's okay with it being repealed
putting a repeal on this amendment right
he did say that but I I I think he's
being he's being polite I think he what
he really wants is for us not to take
the action on this but uh but I think by
by putting it off we're not killing it
we're just saying we're going to do it
at a later date that's
all yeah when when we put it in the
commission then this can be repealed
it's you know say on the same
bill okay we all understand what we just
did that's later okay not today I think
I understand can
I can I see if I understand yeah I was
thinking we could do all of that in
representative Sheen's question and Bill
but it sounds like that's not really
possible so we're just doing so we're
not going to do it we're going to do all
of it later we're going to do this
particular this is this we're doing
today right okay because it has to go
this particular statute we're gonna
we're not going to touch right now we're
going to bring it up later in the
calendar I think I think I got it thank
you so
yeah right that's technically what we're
doing right and I think that when we
started this committee we we we we had
the understanding that if any of these
activities are particularly contentious
that we're going to back off from that
because there is so much fertile ground
out there that we don't need to have
these
fights well thank you all there are two
great committees in the house this is
one of
okay um next on our list yes
ma'am um I have a question regarding the
list before we go to the next one um so
I'm I'm under the impression this is the
list of ones we're going to um review
not necessarily like a removal list this
is the removal list yeah but we're going
to also review them to make make sure
that that we're okay with that they're
on the removal list okay great okay
thank you yeah cuz cuz last time we met
everybody got
assigned and uh well well the one the
one we just talked about was on the
removal list also and we just took it
off so we can take others off as well
but right now there's still eight or
nine still on the list hopefully we'll
get most of
them okay uh representative
Simpson uh
4-c colon 37
archived so I don't really have a lot of
new information on this I reached out to
the senator on the um on the commission
because do we didn't talk about this
last time but this has been the
commission on demographic Trends was
recreated in 2022 and then the house
tried to repeal it just a few months ago
and the Senate rejected our attempt to
repeal so I guess I'm concerned that if
we put this on the removal list we are
um it might mess with the other things
that we're asking to repeal that are
much clearer and that maybe we should
put this off for its own I I I think the
the the mechanics of this would be as
long as the legi admin committee agrees
to put it on the list then it would
probably hand head down the road to a
consent calendar but you're right oh
yeah I mean when it gets to the Senate
gets to the Senate May more we're GNA
probably have to do a little bit of work
with our with our Senate brothers and
sisters to see if they can sustain the
activity to repeal it because because if
they kill it then it's not going to go
anywhere so
right well that's what I'm what I'm
trying to say is if they if they just
told us a few months ago that they don't
want to repeal the commission on
demographic Trends I'm suspicious that
the same Senate would change their mind
on that this month hopefully we we can
get the the uh chair and the ranking
member of the Edna committee which I
think this
originally uh was reviewed last spring
because of the UNH activity UNH provides
the demographics that everybody's happy
with and don't it doesn't anything or
any committee meetings or whatever that
if that is presented in
that that picture to the to some of the
key Senators then you know hopefully we
can sweep that up with with it we get uh
chair chairperson Maguire and U ranking
member of Edna to to do that for us so
that that would be the follow-up
activity and then if um if they decided
they still wanted it they could just
strip that one out they could if they if
they weren't you know what I mean if
they weren't
on on board they can take it they can
they can I guess remove it from
consent on their side if it's if it
makes in a consent on their side they
can remove it yeah I think they would I
think they would amend it right and
strip it out but I I do think knowing
that you know it was it it was itl in
the Senate I don't know why they would
change their tune now you know I'd be
curious to know how that debate
unfolded uh in the Senate because I
imagine that whomever worked on it in
Edna from the house went over to the
Senate and presented their reasoning so
yeah you were there for the Edna
discussion on this yeah and I just yeah
I I would be I would hesitate to
include that Commission in this list
knowing that it already uh was a
challenge in the Senate previously this
term given that we have maybe eight or
nine I mean I guess we'll see where we
are at the end of today what people have
heard back but this seems like one we
could put aside for right now and see
this one the back burner yeah at least
for to and then come back to it even
today if we need to make a not maybe
we'll re Circle back to this one back
burner back
y all right what's next there Mr Vice
chairman okay uh next one is uh 21- I
colon
14-d wait a second me
interrupt got
it
okay so if we could get it to a
committee of conference then we can we
can have the
argument I don't think it's worth it we
want this to go
smoothly it'd be nice if we could give
them something that they would
concur with or not
um yeah since we haven't
really since we haven't done a ton of
work to bring them along with us
I just don't think we should be looking
for trouble if they just rejected a bill
that tried to repeal this why would we
put this in again I just don't think
it's worth the
effort retain put it on the back burner
retain it yeah or let it continue to
live
okay moving moving right along
representative
Romo uh
21- I yes this will be more welcome
feedback um I reached out to the three
members committee and I I didn't hear
anything that initially then I name
dropped my so I
got but it did uh I did hear that from
one representative em and the committee
last firm at once and CH State the
supplies or lack thereof in rep Emmer's
opinion this committee can be ended no
detriment to
anyone I did not hear back from the
other two but um I would hope if they
had
add we keep it on the list okay very
good thank you
representative okay uh 28
DB uh I got the okay to
kill from representative Wier 125j 11 I
got the okay to kill from representative
Harrington and the next one is 356 B70
representative yes I spoke to rep
infantine and he said that he's okay
with repealing this one okay good
another one on the
list okay 404 J1 I spoke
to oh representative hunt okay to
kill moving right
along uh 485 F representative Doan yeah
that was the uh the dup duplicative one
duplicative and that one is going
byby actually can I is that the
long-term SEO Commission on drinking
water yeah it is I so I live in the sea
coast and I represent towns that are
also represented by rep by Senator
Perkins quoka and I know that she's very
active in that commission and I just
wondered if um what her position on it
was like how it's working and all of
that and I got a very different
perspective than the one listed here in
the notes with the caveat that she said
there are Representatives on it that
don't participate so I um so I don't
know I don't want to be so quick to um
chop it if there's
um I mean I can read to you some of what
she sent me that they're working on but
they are actively doing work the Senate
is no this commission oh I see is is
actively doing doing work non
duplicative work yeah yeah okay it is so
let's put this in on the background okay
I have a feeling at the very least it
would be contentious in the
Senate Yeah the more information we get
about these the better that's what I was
thinking and that's why I knew I had
talked to her about it in the past so I
just wanted to make sure I had a
conversation with her before we came
together today okay um so we got one
two three that were taken off and
finally uh
651e interbranch criminal justice
representative Sheen yes I spoke with
representative Roy and they are actively
um using this this commission okay so
this is a
no that leaves us with six okay that
leaves us with
one
2 three four
five
six how do we feel about that
selectively how do we feel
six which are the six can we just okay
uh through real
quick what have the six the six is okay
uh two HB
258 uh 21- I the bottom of the front
page uh 28
B1 next page 125 j11 next page
uh 356
B70 oh yeah that whole that whole
page 404
J1 and that will
be
it because uh you have all those for the
notes oh by the way um my email I was
about 20 minutes in it this morning
trying to fix my email I
somehow messed up with the two- Factor
authorization that we put in too yeah so
all my emails die and I've got
like hundreds to go through
now could you resend the minutes last
couple of because I didn't I didn't get
well I got them probably but I I didn't
see no same
email appreciate it I'm so just to
clarify 651 d two that is one listed for
repeal as well is that
correct 651 is a no the in Branch
criminal and juen Justice that's a no
got it thank
you we're down to six y six on the
recommendation two nose and two
backs interim study so the again the
thought
process uh with uh
the memorial that speaker sherff came
and spoke to us about is that uh he
seems like he's okay if it went to the
um historic
commission and uh I I think we probably
be okay with doing that also
but what we just made a commitment to do
is take it off our list maybe added on
after the first of the year through the
path of of um
the rules committee as opposed to legi
admin and and let give him time to to
review it with the activity with uh his
the fellow members on the
commission that and hopefully he'd be
supportive once he's done that come back
back to us and we can clear that up in
that path who knows with that Rules
Committee Action uh I'm not an expert on
how that would work but maybe we'll we
will have had an opportunity to add
another half dozen or so to our list
maybe we can put it all through that
with that vehicle through the rules
committee so um yeah I was I was
speaking with him and also with the
speaker is that that's a an opportunity
for us to get legislation input u in a
non you an out of cycle opportunity I
guess is through the rules committee we
we're us the legi admin Amendment route
right
now but this would be a different
route just as effective a different
route I I think it might get more
visibility than than what we're doing
with this one but that's
okay we have good potential speakers if
we have to speak to
it okay so we got six going through
legie admin we we've got two hours to uh
to get that written up a documented you
all
set Vanessa to be able to do that you
want some you want to no I just saying
you want some help any more help with
that you need some authorship from any
of
us you think you got it representative
wall you got any inputs on it you're on
that same committee it's pretty cut and
dried
Amendment okay anybody else have any uh
any inputs be be before
our uh our working Representatives go
off and and Cs on this representative do
you have you've been through this before
do you have any any thoughts um no it's
a pretty straightforward process the
only thing is that OSS has to go through
and see if there are any uh cross
references to the ones that we're
repealing in any other
statutes so because it can be trickling
through but as a general matter it's
really straightforward you just list the
statute and and you're um and you're on
your way so oh right I'm going to look
at the calendar here for upcoming
meetings
yeah I thought this was our last
meeting we got to bring in the
chairs and I think so Grill them on the
Committees that they're responsible for
oh EXC me talk with
them yeah
I this is this is the last meeting for
this but we're going to continue because
Charter says it it was my understanding
that the speaker was ending the
committee but no oh no no we're we're on
for another year
okay yes
yes
on turn on that
mic for the
record I'm uh Gregory Hill um
representing Northfield um but this case
I'm representing legislative
Administration um it's important for um
representative Shen to get to OS so that
we have a number that number will let us
uh schedule the next meeting um so so
it's critical that she get going um but
number two um I would like it if someone
from this committee would plan on
attending the legislative Administration
meeting on the 10th uh I'm sorry the eth
that's a public hearing public hearing
for this bill because as you I'm sure
realize um aside from the two members
that uh share both committees um some of
Cu inti some of the information
um comes from other people than those
two so if there is questions that arise
that people come to argue why they're
commission is on is on the list um it
would be good if the people that had
that conversation um we're there to
answer for that well I can tell you that
the chair and the vice chair will be
there and that's up to Matt whether you
want a ranking member or a
representative from your side to come as
well well the ranking member is here um
no I'm talking about rank member of this
committee okay well um I I'm not
designating who or or pointing fingers
but um but it would be helpful I'm sure
will be there yeah we're going to be
there just don't have much of time offer
to Matt if he wants one of the Democrat
members to be yeah I just want to
impress upon the committee that we don't
there isn't the timeline in here in
order to we need to handle everything on
that day pretty much um so so if we can
get the answers to anyone that has
concerns about the commissions that are
that are being asked um it would be good
if we could answer them during that that
hearing what time what time is the
meeting on the year
uh we haven't scheduled it yet but uh
but I would suspect it's probably 10
um and we'll do our best to put this on
First and uh you want to think about it
in terms of attend well I think what's
important is that the member of this
committee who have the conversations
with members of other commissions that
they be an attendance because otherwise
I mean there will be members there right
there will be and and you Mr chairman
were here for this conversation so
that's helpful to some extent as well
however to say yes I had this
conversation they indeed said that they
no longer need to be a commission that's
what we're look that's what you're
looking for that's right in preparation
for the work in addition to that uh or
to follow up on that um it would be good
if if perhaps there was some
consideration about whether this
amendment is going to be divisible um
when it gets to the house floor and and
how those questions are going to be
answered on the floor this is a little
bit different you know we're getting um
the work of one committee passed on to
another
committee that it's not really fair for
that committee to be the one that right
we we hoping for the work that you
insert this in consent calendar you see
that that happening or not happening you
know
um we've had we've had n none of this uh
in front of us now I it would be a it
would be a great big guess on my part um
it's it's been a very Cooperative
committee but um this is this is not
within our baileywick so um I'm not this
year we haven't seen any of these
committees listed so we don't know would
it would do you think it would be
helpful to have a member of leadership
uh either speak speaker or the former
speaker come as an from an introduction
to say what this is all about this
committee uncommit no I don't I don't I
don't um the committee is familiar with
it at least several of the members uh
we've gone through through this process
um honorable uh well representative eel
is uh walked us through and and gave us
our our um well my learning curve on the
whole thing
um youve probably been through this
several times representative wal but it
is um we've done this
before
it's it's never
predictable who wants to come and com
and and
contradict what we think is logical um
but somewhere along the line I will
wager that someone on the floor will
suggest that one of these needs to stay
where it is and and um and why they
didn't show up at this committee I don't
know why they won't show up at at the
legi admin public hearing I don't know
but someone on the floor will ask
something to be removed they'll try to
pull it off consent and then the
question is who's going to be the one
that says this is why it needs to be
there so that's all well you'll have
representation there that's all just not
sure what the mix of it then my work
here is
done anything else I can do for you
no I have a question are you
anticipating changes to sb84 aside from
what we're doing no it's going to be
replace all as far as I'm
concerned if that's what you mean by CH
well I I should have asked the question
first no I I just I'm trying to remember
what the bill was as it came from the
Senate and I wondered if you were change
S sp84 has a yeah has a long and storied
history um it originally started dealing
with Plymouth New Hampshire and uh and
something completely different um it was
it was stripped and then turned into
what you see as 84
now I plan on stripping 84 and putting
this in um and one other
thing what's going to go to a committee
of conference
probably right or maybe maybe not we'll
have to see how it goes there may be
other things the rules was that a
volunteer huh no I don't I'm not
volunteering
anything it sounds like our bill will be
different it sounded like the I don't
know so we'll
see thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank you for coming appreciate
it any other comments oh we want to look
at the calendar um so we have the
13th
Block it's always going to be a
Monday yeah I don't we don't have any
conflicts with any religious holidays or
anything yeah very few people meet on
Mondays and Thanksgiving is later in the
month so that's good are we do we want
to meet the
Monday yeah that sounds
great else we do
we have to bring you a cake or
anything that's my
mom's okay the the U the 13 the 13th at
1 o'clock still okay do you want to do
earlier in the
day
yeah okay
we there's nothing scheduled
on going forward
time so 1:30 on the 13th end the
27th Brad can you help us get that uh
posted okay
good all right so the 13th and the 27th
at
1:30 and uh and Matt you'll let me know
if you want uh to have representation on
the on the eth in addition to I mean I I
maintain that
you know between representative wall and
representative Sheen like there's
there's rep representation there I I do
think that anybody who has been looking
into any of these commissions and has
recommended that they be you know
recommended to our full group that they
be repealed um it would be helpful to
have them there in case any questions
come up so I don't know that any one
person any one additional person is
going to be helpful I think it's if we
had conversations that you know helped
to indicate that that they should be I
want to be as inclusive as possible so I
don't want to exclude anybody so I guess
if if you want to come but aren't
specifically asked to come to speak to
any you want to come just to be
supportive and backup U you do that yes
I was just going to well I guess either
you Mr chairman or representative will I
I have a conflict that morning so to the
extent my um exchange with the
appointments on that committee we over
email is it okay to just like forward
yeah just correspondence Nar that record
or that documentation yeah just give us
some narrative I haven't had any phone
conversations actually at this point EI
anyway so I'll F what I have for email I
think that's perfect yes ma'am yeah um
the only thing I would say is that if we
just got a signal from a chair that that
says it's okay to get rid of it without
the
rationale I think we better find out
what the what the rationale was I mean
on the county state commission I mean
represent maybe you talked to
representative Wier I'm not sure yeah I
did and yeah and because because they
don't have to meet and if they want to
meet they can meet anyway without I
think what she's suggesting is let get
some context yeah we just theend I think
we if some if we have a question I mean
in the case of that particular
commission that was one that was really
focused on by the commission that I
chaired so I also uh followed up on it
although nobody asked me to and the the
thing is that and this is just I want to
share this with the commission because
it's also an interesting fact apparently
these guys have been meeting robustly
the the County State finance committee
they've been meeting robustly over the
last several months or even a couple of
years but
because the the group is not uh
submitting notices of their meetings to
our
calendar it was basically not
trackable by our staff and so it shows
here that they haven't met in TW since
2012 when actually they have been that's
Anis jald was telling us they don't
notify us what they've done so that's
one of those things where you almost
have to call the agency or something but
what they said to me was that they're
very com the agency said they were very
comfortable meeting on an ad Haw basis
which I think is what what chair wer
said um that they were meet comfortable
meeting on the on a ad hoc basis so
although they
were uh not excited about repealing it
when we looked into it at this point
they think the Adcock basis is uh okay
but it's just was interesting to me to
hear that they'd been meeting a lot and
nobody knew because it's not in our
calendar it's just another issue with
commissions but I anyway the point is
that I think we have to give the be able
to give people a rationale rather than
just say the chair said we don't need to
do it
anymore good input
okay with that being said I think we can
adjourn okay we're adjourn cool see you
on next
time